I ka 'ōlelo no ke ola,
i ka 'ōlelo nō ka make.
- In the language is life,
in the language is death.
I am Puakea Nogelmeier.
I've been a professor
of Hawaiian language at the
university for 35 years.
And through our work with
the Hawaiian Language
Newspaper Archive,
we're bringing new light
to Hawai'i's past by
digitizing, translating
and training people to
access over a century's worth
of untapped historical knowledge.
Hawaiians have never
really had easy access
to the insight of their
own people of the past.
A Hawaiian society was an oral society
for a millennia, and then
with the coming of Westerners,
there was a real interest
in written language.
Within a generation, you have
almost universal literacy in Hawaiian.
Compare that to America, which
probably had 50% literacy
at the time, they are
running a very progressive
little kingdom that is
respected around the world.
1834, the first newspaper happens.
By the 1860s there's three,
four, and five papers at a time.
And by the 1870s, there's 10 newspapers
in a population that's
only about 70,000 people.
That's a huge output!
By 1860, the kingdom
recognizes that change
is happening so fast,
population is declining so fast,
and there's letters in the paper saying,
"Those of you who are knowledgeable,
in almost any field, please write it down
and put it here, it'll be safe.
Generations from now, we will need this."
And it was so true, so they're able
to start writing down what had kept
a society alive and
well, on such a limited
resource base as an
island, over centuries.
This is how farming works,
this is how fishing works.
For Hawaiians as a
whole, this is a history
that simply wasn't available
for the last four generations.
From the 1970s, we have what's called
a Hawaiian renaissance.
The renewal of interest
in cultural practices
is what built the language community
that opened up this historical
cache of newspapers.
125,000 pages of newspapers
had been published.
We know only about 75,000 of those pages
have been found in local archives,
but all of the pages in hand
have been digitized and are accessible.
Forty years later, we get 25,000
people who speak Hawaiian,
and the other million don't.
We still have to make
this material accessible
to an audience that
hasn't yet gotten there.
This body of knowledge is
not just for Hawaiians.
This is a global resource.
So the idea of sustainability
is documented there.
Being able to see that is critical
for us today. We don't
have to make things up-
we actually have an
experience base to look at.